[Musique]
Toronto la plus grande ville du Canada
celle avec le plus vaste réseau de
transport en commun
chaque jour plus de millions de
personnes m'ont à bord d'un métro d'un
tramway ou d'un autobus mais de plus en
plus d'usagés le font avec un nœud dans
l'estomac
dans les derniers mois les incidents
violents et aléatoires se sont succédés
en juin une femme ébrule et vivre dans
une autobus en décembre une passagère et
poignardée à mort dans le métro et en
janvier c'est dans le tramway qu'une
femme et poignardée plusieurs fois au
visage
pour faire face à ce climat d'insécurité
la ville a déployée 80 policiers
additionnels dans les transports en
commun c'est pas la façon de construire
une société juste une décision critiquée
par de nombreux élus municipaux qui n'y
voient pas une solution durable c'est un
problème de santé c'est un problème
économique et social il compense les
Torontois nous avons demandé à des
usagers du transport en commun de
partager leur expérience
pour le tramway 13 ans prend le tramway
chaque jour pour aller à l'école
présence policière ou non la jeune élève
ne se sent toujours pas en sécurité de
France pas que ajouter pour plus de
police
pas résoudre quelque chose car les
polices ne peut pas être tout part
21 ans habite en banlieue et passe plus
de deux heures par jour dans les
transports en commun
a remarqué la présence accrue des
policiers mais ne se sont pas plus en
sécurité pour autant
33 ans a complètement abandonné le
transport en commun et vient de
s'acheter une voiture une décision
coûteuse mais nécessaire selon la mère
de famille un moment donné on a plus le
choix quand on veut être en sécurité on
a plus le choix est-ce que quelque chose
qui pourrait être fait pour vous faire
changer d'avis
il faudrait que les soins de santé
mentales soient plus pris en charge
comme beaucoup de torontois Manon croit
que l'insécurité qu'elles ressent
découlent d'une crise plus profonde
pauvreté itinérance sous financement des
organismes communautaires des défis
auxquels sont confrontés de plus en plus
de grands centres urbains Toronto